one minor thing I guess it's not that
relevant now but when the Rubik's books
went better just sit closer so that
people who come mean questions about the
first lecture so one question I think in
the lunch break was how does the theory
I described so far applies to graphs are
not regular so let's say we have some
undirected graph so it's called Lisa V
the degree of V in the regular case it
would be a constant just encoder for
every vertex so this time we're going to
define the laplacian in the following
way so before in the regular case we
said it was the identity - the random
walk matrix of the graph in the general
case we will define to be the identity -
the addition see matrix of the graph
scale by the inverse root of the
diagonal matrix that has degrees along
the diagonal so this diagonal matrix has
the degree of vertex one vertex 2 and so
on on the diagonals in other words so
cool
so clearly this means that a the
laplacian a then 3 UV is going to be 1
if it's the diagonal minus 1 divided by
the average degree of annuity recomment
the geometric average
if you will be unannounced and see it
otherwise so again this definition is
reverse engineer yes these are also
known as the normalizer partying
yes this is not enough so if if you did
not normalize in regular case it would
be the degree times division C matrix
minus the matrix and here it would be
these matrix of degrees families and
semantics man Spain so those would be
the
I never had a family source exemption so
the advantage of working with the
normalization is that the eigenvalues
are all in the same scale regardless of
the density of the girl why for those
matrices the eigen values would be in a
range that depends on the density of the
love like what we talked before was the
hero they've invited up between zero and
two and this turns out to be true also
for internal graphs in this
normalization so how is this
normalization chosen particularly this
way of dividing by the square root of
the product of the degree they seem to
be education because not see that this
is the matrix that is reverse engineered
so that the really portion says
something nice about the row so if you
so this matrix again we it's good to
have atom values real eigen values
because it's symmetric if we sort them
and then we apply the the variational
created calculation of eigenvalues with
a little change of basis what and
something is that everyone another one
will be the meaning over all vectors
summation of edges of XQ minus x3 square
divided by summation of the vertices of
the degree of the vertex x XY squared so
pretty much the same as it was before if
X is boolean this will be the
conductance of the set of which axis
rate indicator vector and then lambda 2
so let's say that x1 is the optimal
solution here that lambda 2 will be the
minimum for X having 0 in a row with x1
of the same expression
and so on the only thing is that since
given is not expression after a small
change of places the sequence of
optimization problems there are not
problems for you optimize away vectors
that are orthogonal to the previous
solutions in the standard sets they are
torn and some weighted inner product and
in this weighted inner product you just
weigh vertices by degree
so after these adjustments we can redo
all the arguments that we did in the
first hour observe that all the other
values have to be greater than or equal
to zero but the smaller one has to be
zero because the constant factor is
proof from that that the largest one is
going to be at most two and the case one
is zero if and only if the graph is
cleared more quality components that the
largest one is two if and only if the
graph has a bipartite political phone so
all the results seen so far apply after
this adjustment but it's always a little
bit easier I find to talk about the
regular case so from now on we will
continue with the regular case but it is
an almost mechanical translation of
statements from the regular case to the
general case
so what I want to do in in this hour is
so look at lambda 2 and lambda N and
understand what are they how to
characterize the graphs so what
interesting applications than there are
from these characterizations how to
characterize graphs were lambda n is
close to 2 and lambda 2 is close to 0 so
remember these moments the minimum now
we are back to regular minimum over all
nonzero vectors that sum to 0
at London with the maxi
in fact it was probably easier to think
of it as being too - miss me
so we look at what happens when lambda
2.is epsilon where lambda M is 2 minus
epsilon and also the case where lambda
lambda n are as far away respectively
from 0 and 2 as they can be with when
they will concentrate it on 1 so this
would be their three increasing case
well the take is about which you're able
to say a few things so starting from
naanum little we said that this
optimization problem the non-uniform
sparse Escott where from what you want
to find a boolean curve such that the
number of colleges is more compared to
the number of separate paths this can be
seen as a problem of which lambda 2.is
relaxation and i were to study how close
the optima of those two problems are and
we show that by showing that if you have
any arbitrary fractional solution here
we came around it to an actual cut to a
boolean solution without a big loss and
that the way this rounding is is but is
simply just sort vertices according to
the numerical value of x of a and then
you look at what is the best cup that
takes initial prefix of these limits and
then the remaining subjects
so this is a recently short row just one
chance to the inequalities but I want to
describe it more in the spirit of
rounding relaxations so we will go a
little bit slower will accumulate a few
extra parts and we use them tomorrow to
see what happens when lambda K is known
this is what kind of clustering
regarding the case so what we do today
will be useful to work okay so first of
all it said instead of looking at this
part says cut and another useful measure
of so being approximately a connected
component is the conductance of a set of
vertices so if I have a set of vertices
I'll call its conductance the edges
crossing the cut let's be manses divided
by a kind of trivial upper bound to how
many I to school across the gap which is
all the edges incident on us so this is
saying if I pick a random vertex of s
and then I move a random step in the
graph what's the probability that I move
outside words
so sets of low conductance assets where
almost all 10 G's involving those
vertices are inside but if you I just go
outside and there are many applications
in what you want to find low conductance
sets for example if if you're on either
side and then you construct a graph
representation where every vertex is a
d'Italia and then the presence of an
energy well in general the weight of an
edge depends on how similar are two
items then a lock on that hand side
instead of data items they're much more
similar to each other than to every
other album so it can be a plausible
notion of clustering especially if the
set is meaning of in some sense among
sensitive this problem so the
conductance of a graph is the minimum
this overall cuts so one has to be
careful because
would be zero if you take s to be the
set of all vertices the cereal today she
comes along run along the top so we'll
look at the minimum on this one side of
the cup
and so they come back on sonograms which
given by the set of fewer than over two
matrices for which this ratio is
smallest
so that's very important optimization
point in that in itself and we are going
to show the they discrete sugar
inequality that the conductance is
controlled by the lambda 2 in this way
so for this direction a just a matter of
running things now that the conductance
is at most what I call the uniform
sparse s-curve before
/ - and that lambda 2 is a relaxation of
the universe Francisca
so this direction just a matter of
definitions visible the interesting
result is this direction and this
direction is a constructive proof it
shows that if you have if you give me
any vector orthogonal to zero or two
metal ones for which this ratio is small
I'm going to be able to find set of
vertices for which the conductance is 1
so we learn and I will do it a bit
slowly
so no submission is that if if we had if
we didn't have those squares rounding
would be much easier so if we're given a
vector wife
that moment will be a bit simpler if I
assume that all the entries are cleaner
than equal to zero but it's not
necessary
so if I had known that any vector Y it
is easy to find and it's absolute work
this is which is in fact a subset of the
support of Y such that they conduct and
so s is it most a really portion to one
without the square
and what we will do is just just pick a
random threshold T in the interval from
zero to whatever is the maximum of value
take advantage of this factor and then
consider it has to be the vertices that
are deeper than this fashion so if we
randomly construct a set like this just
particular non threshold it's saying all
vertices bigger than this get into the
center then we see that on average the
size of the Sun will just be the
summation of these widely with a proper
scaling because of the probability the
vertex belong to a set is a constant
times YB
and the average number of crossing edges
will be proportional to this because the
probability that an edge is one
important s and one in V minus s is the
probability that the threshold is chosen
to be bigger than were you but less than
YB or vice versa depends which is bigger
so I can quickly do the calculation that
the expectation of the number of
crossing edges divided by the
expectation of the size of s will be
precisely this quantity and so there has
to be some choice of T for which the
actual ratio is less than the ratio of
the expectations otherwise even a
contradiction and so there has to be at
least 80 for which the conductance is at
most is much it's only way to see us
going on is that in general since L 1
metrics are
positive combinations of Health metrics
when you get some optimization problem
in which you are optimizing over l1
distances or anyone else so this can be
rounded to a zero one solution with no
nose and it's a general principle okay
so but but then this is not really
helping as a relaxation because it's
exactly the same problem so it's hard to
solve as the previous one but itself but
it's helping because what we're going to
do is to is to take our eigenvector x of
lambda 2 and then turn it into a vector
Y for which this ratio is more and then
this will guarantee the existence of a
cart of smooth conductance so we do the
rounding in two steps so first we adjust
the numerical values of X a little and
then we cut with a random threshold as
it so this ratio will tell us how good
this random cut is going to be
so now I'm given a vector X with entries
Sammy to zero so what I want to do is to
construct another vector Y there will be
some readjusting of the entries of X
such that what I expect to get when I
eventually round this vector while there
are no threshold is no worse than square
root of lambda 2 so such that mu L
rewrite here given it will be a long
expression
suppose Raptor Y such that when I look
at what I expected that eventually from
their own
this is at most the square root of 2
lambda 2 so the square root of 2 times
my ear equation
so the way to think of it is that so
here we are embedding the vertices in
the lamp and we have some cost function
that depends on the distance squared now
we want to modify these embedding such
that roughly after the modification the
actual distances become proportional to
the distance squared it's automatically
impossible but we'll make it with with
the loss given by the square root and he
said it does look like this where to be
some cautious words opening at some
point that will transform a sum of
absolute values into the square root or
in some squares also I need the support
of Y so the number of vertices for which
Y is positive to be less than n over 2
because eventually these argument of
picking random test ships will give me
some subset of vertices which is upset
of the vertices for which Y is positive
but I don't want to get a size bigger
than n over 2 so those will be the two
properties of this first step of the
rounding that I want to achieve that
they this l1 is small compared to the f2
of X and my support this one
so that's the I think would be to say
how to construct this why so the first
thing we do is to the Select course you
have not seen to be X minus the
expectation of X now X minus the median
value
so I'm going to subtract from every
entry the median values of entry so this
new vector has Millions you and so then
the observation is that the Rayleigh
quotient of this vector let's see if
they should give you the name instead of
living in Africa
is only smaller than it was before
so this expose eigenvector of lammeter
so this was longer and then and the
reason is that when you change a vector
by adding a coaster for every entry
you're not changing in the numerator
because the constant will always cancel
out you're only changing the denominator
but how are you change in the
denominator so now summation over the so
what is the norm of NZ v square
well the summation of a V of G B squared
since protein so that's the norm Square
over back to that we obtain from X by
subtracting a constant in every cosy
now the entries of X sum to 0 the
entries of this vector are all equal so
those two vectors are orthogonal to each
other so we have Pythagoras theorem
so the part is this is less than this is
more than just the norm of x squared and
so here we have the bigger denominator
and so the ratio is 1 so we notice in
there any questions we can make the
median zero so then the second step is
that we can write Z as the positive part
of Z minus the negative part of Z so
here the positive part of Z is just Z
restricted to the same non negative
actress
and the negative part is G restricted to
the negativity
maybe it's it yeah let's take learning
once again without we got two orthogonal
vectors because they are nonzero in
disjoint set electrics also advise that
we are kind of going along what was
going on for the extreme of proof like
in the cleanup proof we said is longer
two is zero we can take our back to look
at the positive entries
look at the negative entries and there
could be noise between them because
otherwise that would violate the
condition a number two is two so those
were our components so here I do another
very last version of this we are first
in this case positive or negative
considered too delicate it's better
bigger than the median or smaller than
Dominion and then we get these two non
sets anymore but rounded buckles okay so
what can we do with these factors now I
can say
so I can say the very question for 4G
the compass is nicely in the following
way
all right this looks like it's seated
amongst
so like they knew they know denominator
is that the sum of the denominators if
you only a DV or - C + VC money and in
fact the same is so for the numerous
so this is true for the denominator
should be clear for denominator and it's
a moment of reflection now let's look at
the edges if it's an edge between two
positive vertices then it's taken into
account here and this part is just 0-2
if it's an edge between two negative
vertices it's taking into account here
in here just 0-2 if it's an edge between
a positive and a negative vertex then it
will be the sum of the absolute values
squared
yes so this is left answer that's so
let's say that this is this is the value
of negative value Cu and the positive
value of receiving so here we have the
contribution that is this difference
squared so that's like the absolute
value of Cu plus the absolute value of
CV whole Square and here in the positive
sum we are going to add these up this
minus 0 because this is Z plus V and
this is Sigma sub u and in other side we
are going to be the square of this so
here this edge is giving a contribution
it is Z square plus Z squared so we are
missing the double profit but that's
still on this point
sorry the double pearl is this side so
this side is big okay now this side was
less than lambda P now I claim that
either this ratio needs to be less than
lambda 2 or this ratio needs to be less
than lambda 2 and the reason is that if
this was bigger than lambda 2 times this
and this was bigger than lambda 2 times
this then their sum would be bigger than
lambda 2 times this will be a
contradiction this is a general
principle that if you have a plus a
prime divided by B plus B Prime
so that's at least one of
sometimes it works sometimes it works so
if you have a ratio of two sums you can
upper bound it by the biggest of the
solution so you can lower bound by this
small little so what does it mean for us
that either the Z plus or z minus has
really quotient less than lambda 2 and
both of them have at most n over 2
vertices because a in their support
because this fact would see as median 0
so at most n over 2 vertices can be
strictly positive and at most n over 2
vertices can be strictly negative okay
so either by taking Z plus 30 minus we
have a vector that is non-negative has
only a support of size n over 2 or less
and as Rayleigh quotient less than
lambda 2
so that we can now use that right foot
here so we'll say now let's call
whatever it was C plus root C minus X
again so we're given an axe with the
property that it's all its entries are
non negative this to be positive entries
there are at most n over two of them and
now we want to construct a y for which
this inequality holds so then this will
be less than square root of 2 lambda 2
and we have so the goal is given a
non-negative vector X with this kind of
properties find a vector Y like this
this will be very simple now that we
have produced a comment so much we just
take every entry of what let's see what
can possibly make sense
somali we need to make sure this
denominator it's kind of roughly this
denominator and the numerator is roughly
this numerator and what would make an
analysis of the denominator really easy
is to decide that y is going to be x
squared so that's what they're going to
do and then we worry about the numerator
related so that's what they're going to
define and so our goal so certainly this
makes the support of y the same as the
support of X so this part is fine so now
our goal is to show that we have this
inequality
and now this is just an application of
cauchy schwarz
so it's this is Oh after I've cooked
this inequality had completed my
analysis because someone gives me the
eigenvector for lambda to a shift by the
median I take either the positive or the
negative side I Square every m3 and then
I apply around impression and I get the
final result it is the only I mean this
is the only realized that needs to be
done the rest was just adjusting little
properties of the vectors so how do we
analyze that
so I'm going to say the name
but there is no need for the absolute
value because these are non megabit one
of it actually is
can either to apply for she sports
and so when already we are kind of
getting that when this quantity is small
this body needs to be small maybe with a
quadratic loss
the only remaining step is to figure out
what to do with this
so do another cauchy schwarz
it's enough for every so every vertex
gets this for every edge it belongs to x
2 so this will be summation over the
vertices of told the facts with square
now when we take when we divide this by
summation of X we square and we're going
to get this times this divided by the
square of the summation of XY squared so
essentially we're going to get this
rabbit side so this is what the two is
so what did we so what did we learn that
if you want to find a non exponent set
in a graph
a very useful starting point is some
vector completely like some real number
assigned to every vertex such that not
too many vertices where the nonzero
values and such that an expression like
this is more so if you if you think that
so one way to get a vector like this is
to compute that in vector of lambda 2 so
that will give you this kind of
approximation but say if you're looking
for a small non expanded set but for
many non expanding sets if you have any
other way of coming up with vectors of
this form so this is how you get the
sets and all you're losing is this
square root factor so nothing in this
proof required X to be an eigen vector
Delhi will be is Lex was an eigen vector
was to say that this was at most longer
tool but in general given any vector for
which this ratio is small we can find an
exponent set and if you're given many
such vectors with this joint support you
can find many more expansion if you're
given one such vector and only few
vertices are nonzero
we find this more than exponent set so
this comes up you know the approximation
algorithms for a sparse is cut small
cell expansion and plus
that would be much more briefly telling
what's happening at the other end of the
spectrum so what are the cases in which
London is close to two so you are saying
lemma 2 is 0 if not if the graph is
disconnected learn to be small if and
only if there is a set of smoke
conductors if and only to the pencil
partition of the drug with few edges
going across compared to how many edges
are on either side so what are the cases
in which London is close to 2
so can we say that there is a bi
partition that cuts almost all their G's
when a man is close to two or we cannot
say that because of counter example say
we discussed before so it could be the
graph is disconnected there is a small
biotech rata component and there is some
therefore there is no good
max capped lambda n will be two but
there is no good max cut in the graph so
London is not really a relaxation of max
cut small relaxation of a more local
code or the Turner looking for a sub
graph that is almost bipartite now
remember lambda n was this they say to
minus lambda it is
so I can define this sort of this
boolean problem because it played up
with local bipartite means when you do
the same minimization but over plus one
minus one zero vector
so how to think of this bullet problem
so we have our graph and we're going to
divide the vertices into three parts
each other could be active so the
looking first at sunset this corresponds
to whoever is nonzero and then we are
looking at a by partition of this side
this corresponds to plus one and minus
one and now all the edges that are
saying outside of this side we don't
count them all that is the cross this
partition also we don't count them but
all the energies that leave this set and
all the energies that are entirely
contained on one side of the permutation
those ones we come to so those are
contributing for is a contributing one
so today exact scale what we're counting
is how many edges do I need to remove
from the graph in order for this subset
of vertices to be actually a bipartite
graph disconnected from the rest of the
graph and I'm not just counting them but
I'm dividing by the total number of
edges incident on this table
so say I did some graph what fraction of
the edges incident on it must say remove
in order to convert it into a bar patek
rata component so if the graph is a
better collapse you know
missiny some subset of vertices such
that after removing an absolute fraction
of the edges incident in there that
becomes a biscotti by better grab could
be that the whole graph is plus minus
one so i'm saying the whole graph is
almost perfect but also maybe some
lightly connected subgraph that is
almost battered yeah so so by definition
the lambda 2 minus lambda n is less than
this parameter now that I met a person
but I think it's slight for sparser
Scott with this expansion it's at most a
times this the square root of a times
two months longer
so graphs for which London is close to
two are precisely graphs were at least
locally your second of apartheid several
and this is constructive in the sense
that from an eigenvector for lambda and
I can't find such a sir yeah so perhaps
were lambda 2.is bonnet away from zero
are graphs that are expanded I receptor
the vertices must have a lot of ideas
coming up and graphs where lambda n is
by the way from to a graphs that are not
even locally by patent so that every
time a they look at something and listen
to this we are going to be lots of
crossing edges of the desert and also or
lots of unconscious inside the result so
what happens when both properties happen
at the same time
socially I know it's best to consider
there
so say the iron values of the random
walk matrix it's one of the details and
so does not the same as the eigen values
of the laplacian except that you need to
change sign and add one what if I have a
very well expanded winds so if you have
because not like you look more like an
infantry than infinitely ok so there's
also other it isn't so so it is when you
when you start looking around the vertex
in a graph the hard way then if it said
that I can find in a local paper
partition but then you are going to have
this exponential number of exponential a
linear number of edges coming out of the
set and know that don't count
yeah now it could be that you have an
expanded where lambda 2 is very positive
8 from zero but it's watertight so it
will show up only globally that the
determinant of lambda n will be this
repetition of the government but
normally when you have a when you ensure
the lambda n is fond away from to when
initially lambda n is close to 2 locally
it's also because the graph is a pool
expanded because sort of the decide for
which this happens in particular it's a
non expand insult
yes of about whatever to say next would
be the statement for but today it's a
nice Airy normalization to look at the
eigen values of the adjacency matrix not
only about so if we look at the eigen
values of the addition to make it
be able to keep the same order I will
have to go take a spoon so I'm gonna see
what their militia means lambda 1 will
be 1 lambda n will be more than minus 1
and then lambda K is 1 you can only
clear at a 20 components
lambda is minus 1 only but now so these
are sort of the extremes for the
eigenvalues so it seems that it's
interesting what's happening when lambda
2 is very far from 1 lambda and is very
far from minus 1 so when they make
negative and so let's give a name to
this parameter we call it Sigma 2
because it's the second singular value
of these matrix so what is the largest
absolute value eigen values apart from
lambda 1 which is 1
so the to just be the maximum of longer
than none so what is number is small
they the graph we the will behave a lot
like around long enough in a way that
can remain the precise in a useful way
so first of why would you what would one
expect is kind of behavior so one way to
look at Sigma 2 is that this is the
maximum over all vectors that are
orthogonal to on ones of the quadratic
form
but with an absolutely
now it's it's a bit annoying to have
this photo variety condition
so even get the same we get the same
optimal without the condition if we
modify a so that we're sure that the
optimum is never they all one by two and
one way to do that is to subtract 1 over
n J where J is the matrix that is 1
everywhere
because now if we tolerate the old one
vector as a possible solution what we
get from X transpose ax will just be one
everywhere and what we get from X
transpose 1 over ideas will be 1
everywhere it would cancel off when I
divide yes and now this is another good
interpretation this is the distance
between the one regimes times the
distance between a and B over n change
according to the spectrum
so the other MJ it's like the matrix the
chorus it's a the most expanding the
level graph to thicken up it's a
complete block with wavy or and everyone
but we're not even being more expanded
movies so much say well hey is a dilemma
graph how close is it to this idea
Tina expanded this click skin and if
this is small it remains image that in a
lot of ways a it's like a clip even
though it's sparse graph if I just look
back to what we can with sender so here
in a x anomaly would be a great specify
of the clip
let's suppose that so now here is a it
will show that expanded mixing level
it's a very useful statement in another
study that says the graphs for which
this parameter is small behavior not
like others so take two disjoint sets of
vertices S&T
and now let's see how many edges will be
with one appointee night semana quantity
so is sure that this is roughly what you
would expect in a random graph will be
the size of x times the size of T times
the aura so do you do that then what
so one observation would be that this
parameter Sigma 2 is also the maximum
over all choices of x and y x transpose
a minus pn / j y / normal that's x over
1 so if you do this maximization I mean
this is a part the relaxation because if
you choose x and y equal to the same
expression but there is never anything
to gain by taking action will be
different so so now for example
take X to be the indicator vector of the
set s Y to be the indicator vector of
the side T so that what whatever to that
is that the indicator vector was a minus
Union J times the indicator of activity
will need to be at most even with an
absolute value the norm of x times the
norm of y which is the square root of s
times T times this parameter Sigma to
and now what do we have here one is a 1
t is going to count the number of
registered bullet point in s 1
appointing T and 1 s J 1 T is just s
times T so what we have is that the
number of edges with one is points in s
120 P minus the expected number that you
would get in a random graph or average
is going to be at most
and so if this parameter Sigma 2 is very
small and those said some size commando
and it is actually a pretty small time
so for every two light sets you actually
get as many edges as you would expect
with really good approximation so the
gap it does look like I don't have to do
it
so here they say you know so far every
result has come as a double inequality
between a common problem optimum and the
special co-op and here it's the same so
we can think of what is a combinatorial
problem whose relaxation is this
parameter Sigma 2 what we do think of
how small this error can be and look at
sex food for which the error is maximum
so you can define the discrepancy of a
drug to be the maximum over all such as
simply this joint of these are the edges
between S&T - what you would expect be
valid by
the times so this is a problem of which
Sigma 2 is a relaxation so the
discrepancy of J needs to be at least
Sigma 2 and what we will encode is that
this is a reasonably good relaxation in
fact this is like a block of do
signalization but this is certainly true
voice rhythm I notice here this is just
the definition and here is a comparable
problem here is relaxation it's a
maximization problems of your peers if
this inequality is a way of staining the
expanded mixer number but it is that
this is always need without that in
every graph if you have a vector X for
which this ratio is large but the
section from which this ratio is large
you can find two sets for which the
error is locked the together given a the
discrepancy is boolean so it has to be
small sorry
yeah
so this is just that it's a relaxation
and no did I write the symphony I just
say yes yes yes Sigma 2 is alert system
so for support this direction you need a
running up need to say what someone
gives me a random factor of Sigma tools
for even there's some vector for which
this quadratic form is large and now I
need to follow in two sets of vertices
such a number of edges between them is
not point where they would expect in a
rubber glove so that so this is sort of
the local version of the growth in neck
code where you want to find a cup
there's a number of edges that is not
what you would expect the internal card
and then you find it with approximation
here it's more like another cut global
cup
anyway a sigma 2 is to the this
relationship is to approximating global
castles in the very technicality as
getting a good local cut using lambda
and is coherence williamson
because I imagine is that so one what's
graphs for which Sigma 2 is as small as
possible one limit is the inability of
this needs to be at least the square
root 2 spoon of t minus 1 minus little
over 1 you have the family loves so the
smallest Sigma 2 for which you can have
all these nice properties is something
like 1 over root B and the a graph is
called ramanuja if this is PI this is a
definition this is the theorem visa
definition
so when you have a family of double
engine revs with increasing number of
vertices and the Sigma 2 of these graphs
is as small as you can hope in the limit
of large groups and their other things
are open about constructing and perhaps
like this as Nicky doing a comeback to
this we know how to post our graphs
birthdays maybe it will be the epsilon
here with a publicity construction you
know other monster graphs were the minus
one is a high power
Lanakila we were to Marcus and Spearman
shows up on stock buyback that religion
else followed thee but only point P team
onion but I did leave one would like
such an abyss with other epsilon for
every event and and anything let's sway
of ok so then so next time I want to
talk about the other advantage so what
do they say Ottomans are three of the
four of the part itself